welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
after MERS in drug development from
biomarker discovery to targeted drug
delivery to small molecule drug
detection presented by dr. bill Jackson
founder and chief scientist base-pair
bio technologies
my name is Xavier courtiers and I will
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Jackson I will
now turn the presentation over to him
Thank You Xavier as mentioned my name is
Bill Jackson and I'm founder and chief
scientist of base-pair Bao technologies
the title of today's talk is after MERS
and drug development biomarker discovery
targeted drug delivery and small more
small molecule drug detection in this
talk I have just a few brief slides on
apt immerse themselves and then I'll
jump right into after MERS in drug
development so just what is an after
myrrh the term after myrrh simply means
a part that fits after MERS are
typically small and interact in all the
same ways most biomolecules interact
van der Waals interactions hydrogen
bonding salt bridges high stacking etc
and as I will explain after MERS are
selected by an in vitro process
from large combinatorial libraries of
over 10 to the 15th single-stranded
nucleic acids so how does one make an
app mer well there are numerous
variations but the basic steps are
referred to as selects and are as
follows in step one when it mobilizes
the target to a solid support then binds
the Optima library and washes away the
vast majority that are non binders in
step two the rare binders are eluted and
collected in step three
the alluded fraction of nucleic acids is
then amplified by the polymerase chain
reaction or PCR the entire process is
then repeated typically for ten to
fifteen rounds under increasing
stringency so let's put some numbers
around the larger workflow as it's
typically performed at base pair that
base pair we begin with some of the
largest libraries were aware of
libraries containing over 10 to the 15th
candidate sequences or a million billion
different candidates a select strategy
is then performed under carefully
defined conditions and we use
proprietary methods to monitor the
diversity of the library by the end of
selects the library is typically
converged to about a million unique
sequences representing a billion fold
reduction in sequence diversity we then
use bioinformatics looking at a number
of attributes in order to cluster or
condense those sequences down another
three orders of magnitude to about a
thousand candidates for most part
targets such as peptides and proteins we
can then make use of DNA micro arrays as
a high-throughput screening tool to
further narrow the candidates to just
tens of candidates then depending on the
customer needs or applications we
typically perform some type of
functional screening on usually two to
twenty optimist so to recap in a matter
of weeks we go from 10 to the 15th
candidates to just a handful of
validated binders or apt immersed
after Mars offered multiple advantages
of your antibodies in a wide variety of
context first app Demers are less than
one-tenth the size of antibodies so
sterically they're better able to access
tissues and tight spaces spaces on cell
surfaces both in vivo for drug delivery
for example and in vitro in tissue
histology ii selects itself as an in
vitro process so unlike conventional
antibody production after MERS can be
selected to bind small molecules that
are often non immunogenic or simply too
toxic for successful antibody production
after MERS can be selected in virtually
any background matrix at base-pair we've
selected after MERS in saliva urine
fecal extracts sea water horse urine for
detection of doping agents and race
horses and even mosquito saliva
unlike protein based antibodies or
enzymes after MERS are extremely stable
they can be life alized
and go immediately back into solution
they readily refold and they're not
temperature sensitive so they can be
deployed in hot austere environments for
point-of-care tests after MERS are
readily modified even during synthesis
many chemical modifications can be
incorporated for enhanced binding in
vivo stability and detection can also be
improved common modifications include
fluorophores and quenchers attachment
chemistry's such as styles amines
Fightin's or even click chemistry's
whereas antibody labelled strategies
antibody labeling strategies almost
always result in a distribution of
labels through multiple lysines for
example after MERS can be synthesized
with a precisely defined degree of
labeling the result is that after MERS
can enable much more consistency in
control fourth after MERS are produced
by well understood very mature chemical
synthesis technology so as there is
literally zero batch to batch
variability in their production they can
be readily synthesized
under GMP controls and resupplied
indefinitely after MERS and drug
discovery the unique characteristics and
advantages of Optimas are being tested
throughout the drug discovery process
from the identification of new targets
to the use of apt immersion as direct
therapeutics themselves conjugates for
targeted drug delivery and agents for
enhanced detection and monitoring after
MERS are creating new possibilities and
drug development in the following slides
we'll move through the various stages in
the drug development process and offer
some potential advantages and published
results generated with a burst let's
start with target discovery after MERS
can be selected for binding to specific
cells of interest without prior
identification or isolation of a
specific cell surface target the selects
process is completed with live cells of
interest in this scenario
perhaps a cancer cell line virally
infected cells or other phenotypic cell
types negative for subtractive selection
is used to remove after MERS that bind
normal cells or similar cell lines after
MERS selected for the cells of interest
can then be directly used in diagnostic
or therapeutic applications making this
a step further and perhaps have even
more utility is that novel unknown
biomarkers can be identified using these
same after MERS to accomplish the
accomplish is when simply immobilizes
newly discovered after MERS on magnetic
beads for example incubates
either whole cells or a membrane protein
preparation with the magnetic beads and
then isolate and loop proteins for
identification by 2d gels or mass
spectrometry as a public published
example Jew at a lat LAN Zhu University
in China used cell selects to identify a
bar biomarker for early stage gastric
cancer following cell selects a newly
identified after mer was found
to bind peroxy reduction 4 which was
confirmed confirmed to be up late
up-regulated in the early stage gastric
cancer by Eliza the growing number of
optimist are being considered as direct
therapeutic agents after more
therapeutic saw first several examiner
bodies one chemical synthesis eliminates
concern over cell culture derived
contaminants nindo toxins associated
with bio processing and simplifies the
regulatory process small afterburn size
helps facilitate entry into tissues and
cells some after MERS have penetrated
the blood-brain barrier enabling
treatment of even neurological disorders
after MERS are generally non Amina Jenny
reduced in immunogenicity toxicity
enables higher doses of drugs of drug
and improved drug performance with fewer
side effects
finally after MERS are easily conjugated
for in vitro and in vivo detection
during clinical trials modifications can
be made to protect against nucleus
degradation peg elation can be readily
varied for control greed renal clearance
and even modifications such as
cholesterol have been added to improve
cellular uptake or crossing of the BBB
or blood-brain barrier while maca Jen is
the only after mer based drug approved
by the US FDA many others are in various
stages of preclinical and clinical
trials this table gives just a sampling
including after MERS for the treatment
of various cancers macular degeneration
and pain management to focus on a
specific example researchers in Spain
and investigated tlr4 blocking DNA after
MERS in an animal model for stroke
treatment while stroke treatment with
tissue plasminogen activator TPA is a
valid option and only about 5% of cases
tlr4 blocking after MERS are a promising
non-toxic alternative
in the study imaging showed after more
presence in both the blood and the brain
and the optima showed no toxic effects
on tissues or organs in vivo studies
involving mice and rats subjected to
permanent middle cerebral artery
occlusion the tlr4 blocking Optima
reduced ischemic brain injury when
administered for six hours after an
injury which is the typical time frame
for administration of stroke treatment
continued protective effects were
observed at the final 21 day time point
in the study other therapeutic after
MERS in our own development effort here
at base pair we've teamed with dr.
Michelle Julie a the University Center
Hospital wah wah or Chubb in Lausanne
Switzerland to develop therapeutic after
MERS the bun the cationic peptide ll 37
dr. jelly a's high-profile work on the
role of ella 37 in psoriasis has been
published in journals such as nature and
the Journal of experimental medicine
base pairs generated after MERS with
nano molar affinity de la 37 and
together our collaboration has
demonstrated that the after mer
co-locate co-located with ll 37 under
the skin with the potential to break the
inflammatory cycle of self DNA
recognition that can lead to psoriasis
on another note researchers in China
have reported preliminary results for
selective DNA after mer 2 alpha
synuclein a protein in neurons that has
been implicated in the progression of
Parkinson's disease fluorescence imaging
and fax analysis confirmed entry of an
AB de mer KT peptide complex in de niro
blastoma cells and the team confirmed
that after miraka uptake did not cause
site of toxicity in vitro the optoma
inhibited alpha synuclein new clean
aggregation and association with
mitochondria the optima also promoted
intracellular alpha synuclein decadent
degradation and preserved
neuronal viability in the presence of
alka suits and new clean over x
rushon after murder ugh conjugates can
be used to dirt also deliver drugs to
target cells after MERS can be selected
to bind with a high degree of
specificity to cell surfaces directed
delivery of drug compounds can limit off
target effects an increased delivery to
target cells can lower the required the
dosage and improve efficacy targeted
after more binding can enable entry in
the cells or across the blood-brain
barrier after MERS are also non amino
Jenay they can be conjugated without
affecting selective binding enabling of
modifications to improve stability or
labeling to assess after more drug
delivery that's another example dr.
Michael fauna Luke's lab in Germany is
selected after MERS to the hepatocyte
growth factor receptors c-met for
targeted delivery of the chemotherapy
drug doxorubicin tumour cells in this
multifaceted approach the group has
created a self-assembling nanoparticle
with multiple excuse me multiple
functions including one an abdomen with
specific affinity for the sea mat
biomarker to confirm specificity of the
particle to cancer cells to non-covalent
drug packaging of doxorubicin and three
photo controlled drug release the team
confirmed selective targeting effective
cell uptake and triggered release of the
drug through both imaging and flow
cytometry CMAT targeting was shown to
facilitate cellular uptake and the
cellular uptake was temperature
sensitive suggesting entry by
endocytosis of the nanoparticle
construct also in the study after more
lipid ization increased serum stability
more than ten full lipid eyes dap Demers
were stable in serum for up to 72 hours
and nana constructs were stabled for 14
to 18 hours in serum finally in
demonstrating the utility of localized
photo afflict evasion the brief
application of low intensity UV
irradiation produced 80%
immortality and in targeted
non-small-cell lung cancer cells in just
eight hours separately a team of
researchers from Italy in Luxembourg
developed an afterword drug construct
that penetrates the blood-brain barrier
for the treatment of glioblastoma
in this example platelet derived growth
factor receptor beta is overexpressed on
tumorigenic glioblastoma cells stem
cells and resistant glioblastoma
therefore an anti pdgfr receptor beta
after mer was selected for targeting
drug wasn't wrapped in the life of
philip portion of a biodegradable
nanoparticle construct RNA after mer to
pdgfr beta was then conjugated to the PM
PS or the polymeric nanoparticles after
were p.m. piece cross the blood-brain
barrier and accumulated at the tumor
site in terms of stability researchers
observed a significant increase in
tumour and infiltration at four hours
versus two hours post injection the
later time points were not included with
respect to activity entrapment of a drug
conjugate with low sell salty and the
PNP s increased its bioavailability
resulting in a thousandfold increase in
cytotoxicity as compared to the free
drug in vivo studies then demonstrated
specific glioblastoma tumor uptake and
reduction in tumor marker expression and
cancer bearing mice following five days
of daily intravenous administration apt
immersed two small molecule drugs
switching gears and somewhat amazingly
for the first time last year more people
died from opioid related drug overdoses
in the US than did in car wrecks the
most helpless victims in this new
epidemic are babies born to opioid using
mothers to help address these problems
base parents developed after MERS to a
number of opioids and their primary
urinary metabolites and
conjunction with Vanderbilt University
very sensitive assays using a technology
called back scary scattering of
interferometry are being developed in
addition to a number of after MERS to
opioids and their metabolites base pairs
developed after MERS specific to
numerous other small molecule drugs
including Epis Ilyn tetracycline the
frontline and HIV drug to Nava vir
several several herbicides and
pesticides and THC what is the relevance
of that after me relate labeling in the
selection of after MERS to small
molecule drugs and drug metabolites
creates new possibilities in the study
of drug metabolism fluorescence labeling
can be used to assess distribution of
therapeutic after MERS and after more
drug conjugate conjugates after MERS to
small molecule drugs can be labeled or
complexed for in vivo imaging an
assessment of drug distribution in the
body after more drug conjugates can be
used to reduce required dosing after
MERS small molecule drugs can be
developed for assessment of circulating
drug levels via biosensors or after
myrrh based assays and assays or
biosensors based on after MERS two drug
metabolites can be developed to measure
metabolites in urine and monitor drug
clearance and I'll be showing some of
our data towards this goal later in the
talk so let's talk about distribution a
group in China has developed an app
tumor lysis liposome drug vehicle
delivery system to reduce the off target
effects of doxorubicin they used a
conventional selects against a select
process against recombinant her three
protein to generate after mer candidates
and then the best candidate was
incorporated on the surface of liposomes
carrying the drug for target targeted
delivery of doxorubicin to her three
expressing tumour cells an after
merliah's ohm quantum dot conjugate with
similar size and potential to the after
more lacus own docks conjugate was
injected to assess in vivo drug
distribution
imaging with the photo shown at right
should targeted binding at the tumor
site and study of sacrificed subjects
confirmed increased accumulation of
doxorubicin in tumor tissues in the
after more group versus the non at the
record with respect to toxicity analysis
of ex vivo organs showed significant and
heart liver damage in the docs only
group as expected reduced damage in the
liposome docs group and no damage in the
afterlife ozone docs group very
promising lee 36 days post therapy
survival was 3% in the docs only group
excuse me 0% in the docs only group 40%
in the docs DOCSIS own life resumed
group and a hundred percent
survivability in the after more life is
ohm doxorubicin group reducing dosing
with Abner's researching researchers
from Harvard u.s. UCSB North Carolina
State and Stanford developed an app
tumor directed system for targeted
derivative doxorubicin and camptothecin
to nucleo land a nucleon expressing
tumor cells in this work a peptide
carrier was engineered to carry precise
molar race of ratios of docks and cpt
for combination drug therapy this
peptide drug carrier was then conjugated
to an Optima again sneaked nucleo land
to confirm tumor specificity to the
concert the teaming observed in vivo
efficacy of the abdomen drug complex
at 22:30 fold below the maximum
tolerated dose rmtv of the free drugs
greatly reducing the risk of off target
effects no changes in body weight or
signs of toxicity to major organs were
observed and it was confirmed that the
Optima conjugate entered cells via
nucleo LAN mediated into psychosis
finally the after Madrid conjugate
showed a 58 percent reduction in tumor
size versus Co administration of Zack
Docs and CPT alone
imaging with after MERS after MERS offer
several key advantages for in vivo and
in vitro imaging small after mer size
offers enhanced penetration of tumor
tissues and access to surface targets
after MERS are non immuno genic so
there's no interference with processes
being studied or perturbation of the
immune system after MERS can be labeled
labeled with a wide range of molecules
with no loss of selectivity or function
and several lap timer modifications are
commonly used such as peg elation to
delay renal clearance and extend
stability in vivo as an example research
researchers in China used a DNA after
mer to ebb cam to identify colon and
rectal cancer tissue site 3 labeled
after merge ener eight strong
fluorescence for frozen and deep
paraffin eyes colon and rectal cancer
tissue but only weak fluorescence for
normal tissue direct labeling of the
Optima showed similar results to
antibody detection with a secondary
antibody while two different antibodies
were required to stay in intracellular
and extracellular afgan the after
Mustaine both after MERS has also been
used selectively staying fresh
unprocessed lung adenocarcinoma stitch
tissue without staining fresh normal
lung tissue more on imaging researchers
at a food on University in China
recently selected an after merch GPC 3 a
cell surface protein that is highly
expressed in hepatocellular carcinoma or
HCC tissue the most common type of liver
cancer after labeled with alexa fluor
750 were shown to selectively target GPC
Plaza GPC 3 positive HCC cells versus an
a5 4 9 lung cancer cell in vitro in vivo
experimental and control mice showed
similar levels of fluorescence and major
organs but the experimental group showed
elevated levels of fluorescence at the
tumor site showing successful Optima
specific targeting
with respect to activity the average
average fluorescence intensity s were
approximately twenty to thirty percent
higher ex-vivo compared with in vivo
imaging but the results showed strong
correlation with the correlation
coefficient of point nine six eight data
also showed that selective apt immers
can be used to detect subcutaneous
tumors via near IR fluorescence imaging
making it possible to monitor tumor
response an animal model in vivo without
sacrificing the animal's abdomen or
targeting and magnetic resonance and
imaging somewhat similarly researchers
at John Shu University in China selected
an app tumor against hypoxia-inducible
factor for an alpha hif-1 alpha for
enhanced imaging of hypoxia induced
cancer stem cells hi1 F hif-1 alpha is
believed to be involved in cancer
metastasis therapy resistance and tumor
recurrence the biocompatible app tumour
nanoparticles used in the study
successfully targeted cancer cells in
hypoxic reason regions and significantly
enhanced signal and contrast in them MRI
imaging with respect to toxicity
histopathological examination of major
organs showed no toxic effects from the
nanoparticles peg and manganese modified
magnetic nanoparticles were bound to the
hif-1 alpha after mer and evaluated via
MRI both in vitro and in vivo in vitro
imaging of two different pancreatic
carcinoma cell lines showed a sevenfold
increase in signal which after
retargeting and in vivo imaging of a
xenograft mouse model showed three and a
half fold increasing and signal increase
in signal with after McCarty after Mir
based assays after MERS offer a number
of advantages and assays for biomarker
detection after MERS are easily selected
for binding the proteins peptides non
and non immunogenic small molecules
toxic compound
or cells of interest after MERS can
differentiate between highly similar
compounds and positive and negative
selection can be done to help enhance
that selectivity no antibody related
nonspecific binding such as header
philic antibodies anti species
antibodies or other immunological
effects related to antibody therapies
are found without the MERS and thermal
stability enables field based detection
and a wide variety of climates chemical
synthesis offers zero batch to batch
variability reduced regulatory
constraints and unlimited material
supply Oh
as an example researchers at the
University of Illinois discovered a
lateral flow assay or LFA for detection
of cortisol and sweat cortisol is a
small 3362 Dalton steroid hormone that
is elevated in response to stress in the
study a forty mer DNA after mer selected
for selected for cortisol was used in
the LFA detection was based on the
blocking of gold nanoparticles by anti
cortisol after MERS in the presence of
cortisol after MERS bind in the presence
of cortisol after MERS find cortisol and
a release from the surface of the
nanoparticles the gold nanoparticles are
then available to bind system eeen at
the positive test line downstream along
the lateral flow strip in terms of
performance the lower limit of detection
of the cortisol LFA was one nanogram per
mil which is well below the normal range
of eight two hundred and forty nanograms
per mil color intensity at the test line
also increased in the dose dependent
manner along with that theme biosensors
produce a change in detectable signal on
reversible interaction with the target
of interest in the biological sample the
small size of capture after MERS enables
binding events to take place close to
the biosensors surface for enhanced
detection
after MERS have been widely have been
successfully immobilized on a wide range
of materials and labeled with a wide
range of signaling signaling molecules
without loss of selectivity or affinity
after more stability and refolding
enables biosensor regeneration and the
abilities select after MERS that bind
small molecule drugs and drug
metabolites and complex samples makes
after mer based biosensors a
particularly useful platform for the
strength study of pharmacokinetics and
drug monitoring for pk/pd studies at
base pair we've tested after MERS to a
number of small molecule targets
including Tanaka vir the frontline HIV
drug several antibiotics and antifungals
the oh and the opioid fentanyl we are
currently using commercially available
screen printed electrodes and
square-wave voltammetry to conduct these
studies some of the promises of
electrochemical sensing czar the optics
tree detection for direct readout in
whole blood or other highly complex
sample matrices that light scattering
can be performed with electrochemical
sensing nano molar detection in less
than two minutes is it is feasible with
just under 100 microliters of sample and
sensors can be regenerated for repeated
use so here's a typical 2 square wave
voltammetry result for our turnoff of
ear after mer as performed at base pair
as one can see there's a dose response
to the target in which the electrode
current is increased we estimate that
the limited detection of this assay
platform is somewhere between 1 and 10
nano molar which agrees with several
independent publications using
electrochemical sensing and base pairs
same afterwards it's an off fear and
here's a plot of that dose response with
the electric current plotted in
micrograms versus concentration and
showing a linear r-squared fit of almost
0.95
though electrochemical optima biosensors
offer the potential to reversibly and in
real-time measure the actual drug
concentration in a near patient setting
or even in vivo as an example
application critically injured soldiers
in the field often metabolize
antibiotics and antifungals at much
different rates than the uninjured base
pair is collaborating on a darker funded
project to develop a multiplex bio
sensor for on-site antibiotic and
antifungal drug monitoring an individual
dosing for the military we have selected
DNA after MERS to small molecule
antibiotics and vetericyn meropenem and
the antifungal of lorkhan assault lead
after merck candidates are being
evaluated in an electrochemical sensing
platform a base pair and the top after
mer candidates will be transferred to
our collaborators for multiplex bio
sensor development well it's time pass
fast but thank you for your time and
attention and we ask that you please
leave your feedback and please reach out
to base pair if you have any questions
about app Demers in general or a primer
based application development
thank you dr. jackson for that
informative presentation I would like
also like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2019 as
a final reminder or speaker will follow
up with any questions you've submitted
via email and that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye